hey guys I'm Ryan Wright we're gonna be
checking out this video today called
super fast it's a fast and furious spoof
need to know no more let's watch this
races around the factory in the back
what was it
we're gonna need a bigger how do you do
that he described them and then like
instantly they're always and dancing
they're really
so I tried
as the driver was driving the car that's
doing the driving
Jason Friedberg and Aaron Seltzer make
the worst parody film she really acted
like they all kind of are the same they
go for the most obvious job like sure
thing it's like I've heard that in every
parent especially it has to do it to
Pilate they did like the joke about like
him there was an Asian guy at first the
trailer started off like it's my work
I'd be good yeah like okay it's sha kind
of cool still it does like Vin it looks
like Vin Diesel is doing a good
impersonation yeah I mean the look of it
looked better
I mean it looks for what them they
provide those those writers this looks
better than that that's still not saying
a lot that's the only thing they
literally go for the most obvious joke
and whenever they seemed like they had a
joke working in the trailer like the
finish to the joke was like oh [ __ ] yeah
oh it's kind of what oh wow that a lot
that next seconds ruined the whole joke
for me I do weekly improv shows all of
those jokes eh they did or what we're
talking not to do because they're the
most obvious like not funny I think
they're funny to people who aren't very
you know who haven't heard them as many
times as you know people who watch
comedy movies would or are in comedy so
it's kind of really immature for me time
mature yeah it's also the worst category
on pornhub really which a mature not
into a mature some people are really in
a mature they're like they oh I like the
real
realistic stuff you know it's like those
are just couples but the people that
watch that kind of corn just don't have
a sex life I've heard of some people who
are a couple to it but anyway yeah
superfast yeah the movie looks like crap
it looks like it'll be better than what
they've done before but it might get a
few it looks like it might garner a few
laughs honestly I might laugh a little
like if I caught it like on Comedy
Central or something I'm sure I would
laughs yeah I'm flipping through
channels and it's on I might just put it
on
I wouldn't like go out of my way to rent
it or buy it yeah exactly I think it's
gonna be at the same level Vampires Suck
is gonna be at because it's like yeah I
know it's like it could have been
something really funny very popular
movies and the jokes are all it's just
it's the parody genre has been given
over to the wrong people
yeah we can do really good parodies
believer and if we had that type of sort
of budget we'd be grossing more than I
do you know what saying we had that
technology like people would go and see
our movie more than the actual
fascinators movies I respect that we are
that bit much better anyway guys thanks
for mentioning that trailer was out
really worth my time there if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe but the
real rejects that's right I'm cocky and
this is salamander Sally you can check
out her channel logs skits what more
could you ask for from a pretty redhead
right with my hair that's pretty cool
and you know what someone's either
poison ivy and we're youtubers so we're
gonna put it out there we're a little
late in the game in doing this but you
can follow us on like Instagram Twitter
and you know the Facebook I'll give you
all you guys my phone number so we can
snapchat you know you can just add
people once after
that's ridiculous in shoutouts will
continue so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject outs where you can earn
yourself a shout out by send something
interesting yeah earn it okay yeah say
something like say something like salary
looks hot that's poison ivy or something
like that it was pretty cool yeah I know
but yours only made me feel good no
you're talking to true if you look you
look good like the poison ivy look it
looks good on you me being a [ __ ] looks
good on me conceited [ __ ]